bonjour à tous à nouveau très heureuse
de vous retrouver avec guillaume larrivé
pour ce point presse aujourd'hui je vais
d'abord vous donner quelques
informations sur la vie de notre
mouvement et je vais commencer par
l'agenda l'agenda c'est demain mardi 1er
mars une commission exécutive à huis
clos à 18 heures mercredi 2 mars une
visite du salon de l'agriculture par
notre président nicolas sarkozy qui aura
lieu dans la matinée jeudi 3 mars notre
président se rendra dans le nord pour
soutenir notre candidat aux élections
partielles de la circonscription de
gérald darmanin vincent ledoux il
passera la journée à ses côtés donc je
dis je vous rappelle que cette élection
partielle aura lieu le dimanche 13 mars
mercredi 9 mars je vous préviens notre
journée de travail sur la fonction
publique et la réforme de l'état que je
vous avais annoncé la semaine dernière
sur la partie militante
nous vous avons distribué deux nouveaux
tracts des tracts important le premier
est sûre stop à l'arnaqué socialiste et
à la politique anti famille de françois
hollande
il rappelle les coups de rabot sur le
quotient familial
les coupes injuste dans les allocations
familiales et la réduction des aides à
la garde d'enfants et aux emplois
familiaux
le deuxième tract qui va être envoyé un
sous forme informatique à la toutes les
fédérations de france et sur la réclame
que notre demande mais exactement d'un
état d'urgence agricole sur plusieurs
propositions sur la compétitivité de
l'agriculture française que nous
souhaitons remettre comme l'une de nos
priorités
et puis sur le poids nécessaire que la
france soit retrouvé au sein de l'europe
et du g20 pour lutter contre la
volatilité des prix est bien sûr
guillaume qui est un un élu de terrain
et sur une circonscription agricole
pourra vous en dire plus tout à l'heure
un petit rappel peut-être un petit
flashback aussi sur l'actualité que nous
avons connue en une semaine
je voudrais le rappelle il ya une
semaine nous avions notre président
françois hollande qui était dans l'air
holland holland juan l'époque on parlait
tout le temps de sarko one c'est bizarre
on ne parle pas de r hollande qui je
crois il a bien été contents de trouver
à son arrivée et il confié à des
journalistes c'est donc peut-être
certains d'entre vous j'ai connu des
périodes plus agitée sur le plan social
eh bien on voit là son sens politique
puisqu'il revient en pleine zone de
turbulences qu'apparemment il n'avait
pas du tout anticipé
et pourtant comment s'en étonner quand
au vent les différentes séquences qui
s'enchaînent au sein de sa majorité
dois-je rappeler les propos de martine
aubry qui a déterré la hache de guerre
qui est pour nous un véritable acte
précurseur d'un avenir mortifère pour le
ps est là je vous le rappelle la
première parler de l'affaiblissement de
la france
affaiblissement de la france des maudits
par l'ancien responsable du parti
socialiste sur lequel en effet le
gouvernement est censé s'appuyer après
en plus ce rappelons le des projets de
réforme de modification de la
constitution sur la déchéance de
nationalité qui n'a toujours pas abouti
la loi elle conneries vous l'avez bien
compris elle aussi pourrait faire les
frais et être amendé n'est ce pas ce que
le ministre de l'économie nous a glissé
hier discrètement dans les colonnes du
jdd
en nous disant rien est intangible
comment d'ailleurs ne pas s'étonner que
ce soit monsieur macro qui montent au
créneau pour parler d'apaisement sur
cette loi et qui la défend quand nous
entendons avec stupeur le silence du
président de la république sur le sujet
quant au premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste pour ceux qui ont pris la
peine de l'écouter hier pendant deux
heures sur bfm
la ligne de conduite c'est au secours la
droite va revenir je cite ces mots si la
droite
revenez le père y serait à feu et à sang
rien de moins ils nous jouent donc
quinze mois avant la présidentielle
n'est pas avec n'importe quel mot au
secours la droite va revenir
quel programme quelle assurance dans les
propositions
mais pour nous c'est plutôt au secours
la gauche est encore là pour quinze mois
en effet la réalité c'est que le
gouvernement et la gauche sont en
tension maximale donc le pays est en
tension maximale les projets de loi sont
non aboutis les primaires à gauche vous
l'avez vue sont pour le moins mal
enclenché et dans chaque parti de gauche
les divisions ne cessent d'exister que
vous preniez le parti socialiste il y a
plusieurs tendances que vous preniez les
verts il ya plusieurs tendances que vous
preniez l'extrême gauche il ya plusieurs
temps dans toutes ses ramifications
n'aboutiront jamais à une politique
cohérente et il ne reste que 15 mois
pour essayer de redresser une france qui
vous l'aviez compris est en train d'être
abîmés et bien loin d'être apaisées tel
que cela avait été proposé
alors parmi les sujets avant que je
laisse la parole à guillaume larrivé qui
va vous faire un point d'étape sur la
loi elle comme riz et sur d'autres
sujets un mot aussi sur les déclarations
pour le moins surprenantes de madame
royal
en effet je vous le rappelle la ministre
de l'énergie a indiqué hier sur france 3
être prête à donner le feu vert à la
prolongation de dix ans de la durée des
centrales nucléaires qui passerait ainsi
de 40 à 50 ans sous réserve quand même
rappelons le de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire
or vous le savez pour respecter la loi
sur la transition énergétique
la cour des comptes dans son rapport
annuel a estimé qu' edf devait fermer
l'équivalent de 17 à 20 réacteurs pour
respecter justement l'objectif de cette
loi qui est
50% de nucléaire en 2025
alors de qui se moque t'on nous avons là
une illustration de l'hyprocrisie voire
de larnack socialiste c'est-à-dire deux
discours c'est à dire que la même loi
présenté par madame royal elle même qui
était donc la transition énergétique
avec des engagements qui avaient été
votées devient d'un coup caduque
c'est donc pour cette loi de transition
énergétique
un enterrement de première classe pour
nous mais est-ce aussi la position du
gouvernement
nous approuvons cette décision elle ne
fait d'ailleurs que reprendre les propos
de notre président nicolas sarkozy en
mars 2015 en visite à fessenheim qui
rappelait alors qu'il discutait avec les
ouvriers de fessenheim que justement il
était souhaitable d'étudier la pause ici
la possibilité de maintenir ses
centrales donc nous exhortons maintenant
le gouvernement à faire sa propre
révolution et à sortir de ces petits
compromis qui sont des compromis de
politique à l'ancienne quand l'enjeu est
si capital et maintenant je laisse la
parole à guillaume merci si l'on en
croit une dépêche de l'afp
le gouvernement s'apprête à annoncer le
report de l'examen en conseil des
ministres de la loi sur le travail
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on assiste en haïti en direct à une
implosion de la majorité il n'y a
aujourd'hui plus de majorité
parlementaire plus de lignes directrices
plus de capacité pour le président de la
république et le premier ministre à
faire voter un texte par une majorité
parlementaire qui est en train de
s'évaporer d'imploser de ceux de se
dissiper alors on verra si un texte est
présenté un jour au conseil des
ministres
on a lu comme vous cet avant projet de
loi et on est très désireux de nous de
pouvoir le discuter article après
article parce que il ya 5 millions sept
cent mille chômeurs
la france s'est enfoncé dans le chômage
de masse dans la croissance zéro et il
ya urgence à modifier les paramètres du
droit du travail pour permettre aux
entreprises d'embaucher plus facilement
donc nous souhaitons pouvoir débattre à
l'assemblée nationale
très concrètement très précisément
article après article d'un projet de
simplification radicale du code du
travail et nous sommes ici en
propositions on a fait des propositions
très approfondie très précises sous la
direction d'eric woerth vous en souvenez
il ya eu un gros travail qui a été
réalisé lors d'une convention sur le
code du travail et nos propositions sont
sur la table nous pensons que
l'entreprise doit être le lieu principal
du dialogue social et de l'adoption de
normes organisant le travail ça veut
dire que la négociation
interprofessionnelle doit se limiter à
quelques grands sujets transversaux mais
c'est bien aux branches et plus encore
aux entreprises de s'organiser de
négocier l'accord d'entreprise à
vocation être la norme de droit commun
et l'accord doit donc primer sur le
contrat de travail sauf sauf exception
il nous paraît essentiel de donner aussi
aux entreprises la liberté de se
réorganiser sans attendre le moment où
elle se trouve en réalité au bord du
dépôt de bilan ce qui veut donc dire
très concrètement que le motif de
réorganisation de l'entreprise doit
constituer un motif suffisant pour
justifier des évolutions dans le
recrutement et dans la gestion des
ressources humaines
nous plaidons aussi vous le savez depuis
plusieurs mois pour un plafonnement des
indemnités prud'homale et nous pensons
que la démocratie au sein des
entreprises ne doit pas être confisqué
par les syndicats la question du
monopole de la candidature aux élections
internes aux entreprises doit être
évidemment posée il ya aucune raison
pour que dans la france de 2016
on reste figée dans un système hérité en
réalité de 1945 il faut introduire
vraiment de la démocratie au sein de
l'entreprise et ça passe par une
évolution tout à fait significatif que
nous appelons de nouveau on demande
aussi il faut le rappeler l'abrogation
du conte pénibilité parce que là aussi
il faut être extrêmement cohérent on
peut pas d'un côté prétendre vouloir
simplifier la vie des entreprises
discours gouvernemental nouveau tout en
maintenant des boulay attachée au pied
des entreprises notamment des pme
le conte pénibilité a été une faute
lourde de ce quinquennat et nous
appelons le gouvernement à l'abroger
en disant cela j'ai bien conscience
qu'on a assez peu de chances d'être
entendues à court terme puisque encore
une fois l'état de la majorité est telle
que cette discussion parlementaire est
extrêmement mal mal engagée et nous le
regrettons vraiment parce que
il est impératif de trouver des voies et
des moyens permettant aux entreprises
d'avoir au fond un ballon d'oxygène
c'est ça les entreprises de france elles
ont besoin d'un ballon d'oxygène
elles sont asphyxiés par la
surréglementation par la bureaucratie
par les normes par les charges par les
taxes de toute nature et tout ça finit
par détruire le modèle social français
qui n'existe plus il ya plus de modèle
social français lorsqu il y a cinq
millions sept cent mille chômeurs il ya
donc urgence de simplifier radicalement
le code le code du travail
quelques mots et j'en terminerai par là
sur un autre sujet d'actualité de la
semaine demain à l'assemblée commence la
discussion en séance publique sur le
projet de loi
on appelle communément projet de loi
urvoas relative donc à la lutte contre
le terrorisme depuis portant aussi
diverses dispositions sur la procédure
pénale avec eric ciotti olivier marleix
qs pierre lellouche
je présenterai au nom des républicains
un certain nombre d'amendements pour que
ce texte soit un texte utile ça sera un
moment de vérité
il ya quelques semaines lorsque
jean-jacques urvoas a été nommé à la
chancellerie
nous avions dit ici que nous l'appelions
à solder le passif des années taubira le
moment de vérité
c'est cette semaine à l'assemblée le
gouvernement donnera t'il oui ou non un
avis favorable aux amendements que nous
présentons ces amendements très
concrètement c'est quoi d'abord nous
voulons en finir avec les années taubira
nous proposons donc de rétablir les
peines plancher pour les délinquants
récidivistes et les délinquants les plus
violents nous proposons d'abroger la loi
de 2014 qui avait créé la contrainte
pénale c'est-à-dire la mesure évitant en
réalité à des délinquants de passer une
seule journée en prison
je rappelle d'ailleurs que là aussi il
ya urgence
que si on modifie pas l'état du droit au
1er janvier 17 la contrainte pénale
s'applique pour l'ensemble des délits ce
qui est objectivement complètement
délirant donc on demande au gouvernement
de nous suivre sur ce sujet avec les
amendements que nous présentons pour
établir les peines planchers pour
supprimer la contrainte pénale et donc
pour solder le passif des années taubira
ça c'est le premier bloc on a un
deuxième bloc d'amendements au nous
sommes en initiatives pour durcir le
régime pénale et pénitentiaire des
détenus terroristes
on a été au siège des républicains
certain nombre à faire des propositions
ces derniers mois et là on a 23
amendements très précis pour supprimer
toutes les réductions de peine et les
aménagements de peine pour les détenus
terroristes
nous proposons aussi la perpétuité
réelle pour les criminels terroristes et
nous proposons aussi dans certains cas
une mesure de rétention de sûreté post
peine pour certains des détenus les plus
dangereux donc on a tout un paquet
d'amendements qu'on présentera demain
avec eric ciotti avec olivier marne ex
avec pierre lellouche et on souhaite
vraiment que ce soit un moment de vérité
face à la menace terroriste islamiste
extrêmement élevé il ya un devoir
d'efficacité et ici nous proposons des
solutions pour renforcer la sécurité des
français
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire avec
brigitte à ce stade est ce que vous avez
des questions pour nous pour le
secrétaire général des républicains qui
est présent
j'arrive comme ça donc je passais des
questions oui bonjour on entendu
beaucoup de positions différentes de la
part du parti de personnalités du parti
les républicains notamment certains qui
disait que la loi le comment il était
plutôt positif qu'il faudrait donc la
voter quelle est la position du parti
sur le vote de la loi
on a le même bravo tu es pour s'abstenir
ou voter contre j'ai pas entendu de
positions extrêmement divergentes
j'ai beau chercher beaucoup de
divergences mais franchement là on n'en
trouve pas on trouve des expressions
différentes les mots différents
globalement tous ceux qui sont exprimés
beaucoup sont exprimés là dessus je
m'étais exprimé le premier parce que les
missions de au moment où les chaussons
sont venus c'était qui est pas il n'y a
pas d'ambiguïté on est favorable au
principe même de la loi elle comme reese
rendre moins rigide code du travail on
le prône depuis longtemps commencé à
contribuer cela même si on n'était pas
allé suffisamment loin la convention
qu'on a fait ici c'est notre référence
la convention qu'on a fait ici sur le
marché du travail
jean-philippe l'était en octobre ou
novembre je ne sais plus à l'automne
était très clair référendum d'entreprise
c'était un sujet d'opposition
extrêmement frontale avec la avec la
gauche avec les syndicats nous
souhaitions le référendum d'entreprise
on souhaite la démocratie politique
évidemment on souhaite aussi la
démocratie sociale la démocratie sociale
à un moment donné quand on veut plus de
pouvoir dans l'entreprise c'est aussi de
faire appel aux salariés pour décider
d'une mesure particulière de leurs
conditions de travail de leurs contrats
de travail de la rémunération
tous sujets peuvent venir au référendum
d'entreprise en sang sans que ce soit à
l'initiative des syndicats puisque ce
qui est dans le projet de loi le
connerie c'est l'initiative des
syndicats lorsque l'accord n'est pas
majoritaire mais qu'il est 1 30% et
c'est un truc à la française la vérité
c'est qu'un chef
reprise me semble-t-il n'est pas dans un
mode de gestion et donc il doit pouvoir
faire lui même décider lui-même de la
pelle ou non au référendum d'entreprise
avec une résultat qui s'impose à tous à
ce moment là c'est pas une consultation
c'est un résultat qui s'impose à tous
donc on est favorables au référendum
même si c'est pas tout à fait le même
référendum on est favorable à un
assouplissement des conditions de
rupture du contrat de travail
on voit bien que trop de deux conditions
de rupture créer une impossibilité ou
une incapacité ou une sorte de
d'hésitation très fortement qu'on puisse
dire avant de recruter
donc on pense que faciliter le
recrutement si aussi de mettre les
règles du jeu la rupture du contrat
trail et de façon claire le projet elle
comme riz commence à contribuer à cela
puisque toute une série de dispositifs
qui vont dans ce sens je pense par
exemple aux licenciements économiques le
motif de réorganisation de l'entreprise
est à l'intérieur de la loi c'est ce que
nous demandions dans notre propre
convention sur le marché du travail
on demande aussi est ce que les pouvoirs
d'interprétation du juge soit limité car
lorsque le juge interprète la situation
économique de l'entreprise sait pas où
ça s'arrête
donc il faut que ce soit sur une base
factuelle et cette base factuelle on la
trouve aussi dans le projet de madame
elle comprit alors en partie tout ça
doit être mieux probablement mieux
organisé mieux travailler plus mais
enfin on trouve ces principes
et c'est sur le motif de rupture
on doit pouvoir les intégrer aux
contraintes rails je suis pas sûr que
madame elle comment ils le disent
donc il ya beaucoup de sujets où nous on
pense que il est le projet le conneries
comme on dit entre guillemets va dans le
bon sens ils contribuent à des rigidités
fier le marché du travail et le droit du
travail
il donne plus de pouvoir aux entreprises
et à la négociation dans l'entreprise ou
dans la branche parce que c'est pas dans
l'entreprise mais il y a
travail qui doit être qui doit être
continuée comme guillaume tout à l'heure
le disait à propos de la loi je sais pas
comment il s'appelle
et on voit de la loi euro devraient nous
on fera des amendements qui iront plus
loin que la loi elle connerie mais aux
standards européens
la vérité c'est que on a besoin d'être
un standard standard europe et en
respectant les limitations de vivre mais
on a besoin d'eux on a besoin de cela
donc oui on je ne sais pas ce que dira
le groupe vous êtes au parti mais le
groupe a commencé à en parler cette
semaine je pense et puis la semaine
prochaine le projet de loi il est
repoussé toute façon ça nous laisse du
temps
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'il veut pas
y avoir de synthèse sur ce type de sujet
on doit aller plus loin il faut il peut
pas y avoir de synthèse et la synthèse
hollande yens sur le sujet c'est juste
rien du tout c'est de l'eau tiède et
l'eau tiède ça sert à rien c'est trop
chaud pour ce pourboire et c'est trop
tiède pour se laver donc ça sert à rien
et ce projet de loi il ne sert à rien si
les démanteler vraiment et comme ils
comment il va commencer à être démantelé
parce qu'on va commencer à y mettre a
commencé à considérer qu'il faut des
conditions supplémentaires que ça peut
pas marcher dans quelles conditions et
c'est donc ça ça ne marchera pas et on
risque d'assister une veste détricotage
du procès du projet plus tôt
ll comrie qui enfreint procès de
libéralisme outrancier
c'est pas le cas il faut aller plus loin
que la proposition de madame belle
connerie et en allant
mais en continuant sur le chemin qui a
été tracé par le par le gouvernement il
n'y a pas de synthèse hollande yens
possible entre je dirais la la le ps
presse le ps de toujours et est là elle
je pars libérale du parti socialiste
je pense que je suis une victoire mais
on voit bien que nos idées progressent
dans l'opinion et elles progressent
aussi
c'était extraordinaire parce qu'on en
arrive même à convaincre le gouvernement
maintenant donc c'est beaucoup
sauf que le gouvernement il n'est pas le
mieux placé pour mettre en oeuvre les
propositions que nous faisons d'abord
les propositions ne sont pas isolés si
vous réformer le marché du travail tout
seul ça ne sert à rien si vous rendez
plus simple le licenciement pour des
raisons économiques on parle pas de
motifs mais de photos chose comme ça
mais si vous rendez plus simple les
licenciements sur le mode sur les
raisons économiques il faut évidemment
que l'économie elle fonctionne c'est la
même chose que de mettre 500 mille
personnes en formation
si vous mettez cinq cent mille personnes
en formation et que derrière et ils
l'économie ne suivent pas alors à ce
moment là au fond vous fragilisez tout
le monde où vous décevez tout le monde
donc c'est un ensemble
c'est un bloc cohérent entre le niveau
des prélèvements obligatoires
la fiscalité française la compétitivité
le niveau de dépenses publiques on
considère comme aujourd'hui
atteignant des sommets qui rendre la
france plus compétitive
c'est un ensemble donc la réforme du
marché du travail elle doit fonctionner
avec un ensemble plus vaste de
redressement de notre économie et donc
de mesures très très puissante
si c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui tout
seul tu interviens merci si je peux me
permettre un complément en rebondissant
sur ce que disait mathieu gouard sur la
déchéance de nationalité
on voit bien ce que veut faire françois
hollande faire de la triangulation sur
de nombreux sujets c'est d'abord un chef
de parti qui aime faire des synthèses et
c'est de chercher une idée ici une idée
là et puis ils essaient de touiller tout
ça et ça s'appelle de la triangulation
mais sur cette affaire de déchéance de
nationalité qui était un des éléments de
la lutte antiterroriste il faut de la
cohérence c'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure je disais que cette semaine à
l'assemblée ça va être un moment de
vérité
on a eu un gouvernement qui pendant
trois mois nous a fait débattre de la
révision constitutionnelle relative à la
protection de la nation
et là en un texte législatif sur lequel
on l'appelle la cohérence on peut pas
d'un côté faire voter par l'assemblée
nationale
la déchéance de nationalité pour les
terroristes et refusent et des
amendements qu'on propose pour durcir le
régime pénale et pénitentiaire des
terroristes juste un chiffre en 2012
2013 2014
vous avez 56 terroristes condamnés qui
ont fait l'objet de mesures de
libération anticipée
c'est un chiffre tout à fait officielle
qui n'est pas contesté par la
chancellerie
cinquante six terroristes condamnait
faisant l'objet d'une mesure de
libération anticipée
nous disons ici aux républicains stop
ces mesures de réduction ou
d'aménagement de peine pour les détenus
terroristes
elles sont extrêmement dangereuses il
faut de la cohérence il faut de la
cohérence sur tous les sujets sur les
sujets économiques et sociaux mais aussi
sur les sujets soient les sujets
sécuritaires
on a un gouvernement de gauche qui gère
une france qui est de plus en plus à
droite
donc c'est compliqué pour le
gouvernement de gauche et ça se voit
d'ailleurs ça crée des fractures qui
sont totalement me semble-t-il
irréconciliables les positions de la
gauche aujourd'hui sur sur l conneries
comme sur la déchéance de nationalité
comme sur beaucoup d'autres sujets ça a
été le cas d'ailleurs au moment de la
loi macron elles ne sont pas
conciliables ça que vous parlez de la
synthèse impossible
elles ne sont pas conciliables tout
simplement parce que la france pense à
droite et le gouvernement est à gauche
c'est compliqué à faire mais ça marche
pas ça ne marche pas